[موسيقى]
ماذا لو أخبرتك أنه من الممكن
سحب الوقود الذي يشغّل
طائراتنا من الهواء بشكل جيد
، ستخبرك شركة ناشئة تُعرف باسم شركة طيران أن
ما نقوم به هو في الواقع
جمع ثاني أكسيد الكربون مع الهيدروجين
و  تحويله إلى وقود لدينا والذي
يصبح بعد ذلك المادة الأولية للعديد من
الأشياء الأخرى بالإضافة إلى
فودكا [الموسيقى] في عملية تدعي أنها ليست
محايدة كربونيًا فحسب بل سالبة الكربون
الآن تقول الشركة إنها يمكن أن تستخدم نفس
عملية التقاط ثاني أكسيد الكربون الضار
من  الغلاف الجوي وتحويله إلى
وقود مستدام يمكنه توليد الطاقة ،
لذا فإن ما نبحث عنه هو
نظام التحليل الكهربائي للماء ، هذا النظام هو ما
يأخذ كل الكهرباء
ويتحول إلى طاقة كيميائية تسحب
الكربون من الهواء وتحويله
إلى وقود نفاث يشبه  معقدة بعض الشيء ،
لذا طلبنا من الدكتور ستافورد شيهان أن
يرشدنا خلال العملية ، فهو
CTO في الشركة والذي يحمل أيضًا درجة الدكتوراه في
الفيزياء الكيميائية من جامعة ييل في هذا المفاعل
حيث وضعنا ج  المحاليل هي
مواد مملوكة لنا وهي نوع من
الصلصة السرية الخاصة بنا في شركة الهواء ، نضع
محفزاتنا في هذا المفاعل وما
يفعلونه هو التأكد فقط من أن
ثاني أكسيد الكربون والهيدروجين يلتقيان
بالطريقة الصحيحة تمامًا لإنتاج الوقود لدينا
جميع منتجاتنا  لدينا أساسًا
غاز الهيدروجين ، لدينا غاز ثاني أكسيد الكربون ، وقمنا بدمجهما ، وقمنا
بصنع هذه
المركبات السائلة ، ثم هنا نوعًا ما
تفصل بينها استنادًا إلى
النقاوة والثقل ، هل حصلت على ذلك
بشكل صحيح في الغالب ، نعم لقد فهمت ذلك
تمامًا.  لقد حصلت على هذا الأمر بشكل
صحيح جدًا ، لذلك يتم
إنتاج الهيدروجين من الماء ، لذلك نبدأ
بالمياه هنا ، لذلك نأخذ الماء الذي
قسمناه إلى أكسجين الهيدروجين ،
والأكسجين هو فقط انبعاث الهيدروجين الذي
يمزج مع ثاني أكسيد الكربون ثم
تحول ذلك إلى  نتاج
رد فعلنا التحفيزي ، لذلك هذا هو جلد التقطير لدينا ،
أعتقد أنه تقني قليلاً أكثر من كونه يشبه
معمل تقطير الويسكي النموذجي
في الوقت الذي تحرق فيه الطائرة هواء وقود الطائرات هذا
تدعي الشركة أن العملية بأكملها
ستكون محايدة كربونيًا مما يعني أن
كمية ثاني أكسيد الكربون التي تستخدمها لإنتاج
الوقود ستكون تقريبًا نفس كمية
ثاني أكسيد الكربون التي يتم إعادتها إلى الغلاف الجوي
أثناء الرحلة ، لذلك على عكس
وقود الطائرات التقليدي ، لا تضيف هذه العملية المزيد
تلوث الكربون الضار في غلافنا
الجوي الذي بدأته بالفودكا ، هذا
النوع من المستهلك الذي يواجه المنتجات ،
يبدو وقود الطائرات بمثابة قفزة كبيرة حقًا.
أنت تعلم أن
التكنولوجيا هي نفسها حقًا عبر
كل هذه الأسواق الصناعية الكبيرة
حيث يمكن أن يكون لدينا أكبر تأثير
ممكن ، ولكن للوصول إلى تلك
الأسواق الصناعية الكبيرة مثل وقود الطائرات ،
والتي تُعرف تقليديًا بأنها
أصعب الصناعات
لإزالة الكربون ، ستذهب
يستغرق الأمر وقتًا وسيستغرق الكثير من المال
والكثير من الجهد ، لطالما كانت الرؤية
موجودة ولكنها تتطلب المزيد
نهج نظامي وطول العمر بدلاً
من مجرد محاولة الركض قبل
السير
في اتحاد النقل
الجوي الدولي الذي يمثل ما يقرب من 300
شركة طيران حول العالم
التزمت بانبعاثات صافي صفر من الكربون بحلول
عام 2050. حاليًا صناعة الطيران
مسؤولة عن ما يقرب من 3 في المائة من
انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون في العالم لتحقيق هذا
الهدف النبيل المتمثل في أن تكون صافي الصفر ،
تتوقع الصناعة أنها ستحتاج إلى استخدام
وقود أكثر استدامة مثل شركات
الطيران وتقول شركة طيران بالفعل إن بعض
شركات الطيران وافقت على شراء
ملايين الجالونات من
وقود الشركة.  لنضطر إلى تطوير
هذه العملية من أجل تلبية
جميع تلك الاحتياجات ، لذا سيتعين
علينا توسيع نطاق هذا المصنع بقوة كبيرة جدًا
في المصنع التالي الذي نقوم
ببنائه حاليًا وهذا المصنع يبلغ حجمه حوالي 100
ضعف حجم هذا المصنع التجريبي
أننا في الوقت الحالي ، لذا ستحتاج هذه المنشأة
دائمًا إلى العمل من أجل
إجراء البحث والقيام بذلك  قام
بالتجريب لفهم كيفية بناء
تلك المصانع الكبيرة
بكفاءة في أغسطس ، أجرت القوات الجوية الأمريكية
رحلة تجريبية صغيرة تدعي الشركة
أنها أول معركة محايدة الكربون في العالم
بواسطة محرك نفاث يستخدم
وقودها المشتق من ثاني أكسيد الكربون في عام 2020.
دخلت Force في شراكة مع شركة مماثلة
12 والتي تعمل أيضًا على
إنتاج وقود الطائرات المشتق من ثاني أكسيد الكربون ،
متى تتوقع أنه
يمكن استخدام هذا الكانوبيلا في رحلة تجارية منتظمة
قد يكون URI عليها ، ونحن
نعمل مع أحد شركائنا
بالفعل  اختبار على طائرة تجارية
العام المقبل بحلول الوقت الذي يتم فيه إنشاء منشأتنا التالية
وتشغيلها في عام 2024 ، نتوقع أن
نطير بأول رحلة تجارية فعلية على الإطلاق
بالوقود.
أن هذا هو الهدف من خلال التكنولوجيا ، وبالنسبة
لنا فإن تغير المناخ هو التحدي الأكبر
الذي نواجهه هو الإنسانية
حتى الآن ، لذلك إذا كان بإمكاننا العمل على
التقنيات التي تأخذ  لقد كان
يُنظر إلى قبعة ذات مرة على أنها مشكلة
وتحولها إلى حل ، فهذا فوز هائل
وهذا ما ننهض به كل يوم
للعمل عليه وهذه هي الطريقة التي نفكر
بها في أعمالنا